ok let's get into audience questions for
the week I genuinely love this first
question I have a lot to say about it
hey David what wastes of money are you
shocked people still fall for there's
like a big one which I'm gonna lead up
to but a couple of small things are I am
always surprised when people buy
insurance on relatively small purchases
and I understand the idea that if it's
something very expensive you actually
may suffer a hardship if it breaks and
you have to fix it or replace it I can
understand getting an insurance policy
replacement plan extended warranty or
whatever but particularly as someone who
worked at Circuit City and sold a lot of
these inexpensive insurances and service
plans and stuff like that it really
doesn't make sense on small purchases
and I don't know why anybody continues
to buy it and the way I I now don't get
insurance on anything no service plans
no warranties any of that stuff
and the calculation I've made is that
all of the stuff I never got insurance
on and it never broke that's thousands
upon thousands of dollars in insurance
dollars that I never spent so I'm so far
ahead at this point that I feel like I'm
properly kind of like self insured
health insurance of course I have you
know home insurance I think I have to
have it but I have that but insurance
plans on really inexpensive items I
think are a waste of money
in general stuff that people don't use
and don't cancel I'm still surprised at
the number of people of friends I have
who say I really got to cancel that
credit monitoring thing or whatever I
never look at it I don't even know what
my access code is but I just keep paying
the 25 bucks a month you got to cancel
that stuff that is a stunning waste of
money to me but the really the the big
one that shocks me
how are people still falling for pyramid
schemes and as it has been more friendly
more sort of appealingly renamed
multi-level marketing I don't know how
people still fall for it the number of
people I'm friends with on Facebook that
are doing a whole bunch of these
multi-level marketing things is is
absolutely shocking to me and whenever
it comes up
in sort of social settings I I'm not
trying to have huge conflicts with
people in my personal life so I will
often be very very polite and actually
say oh how many sales have you actually
made and they'll say well you know for
now I really only purchased my supply of
stuff so that I have demos and I've only
made like a sale or two and I say oh
okay so but now you have all that stuff
that you can sell over the next few
months and they'll say well actually
you're in order to remain as a reseller
you actually have to place an order
every month and then I say oh so every
month you actually have more stuff you
have to buy regardless of whether you're
making any sales and they say yeah you
do but I'm building my business and all
this stuff it's stunning stunning to me
that people are still falling for that
stuff and I think one aspect of it which
is wages have been stagnant for however
long they've been stagnant um people are
looking to make some extra money
people want autonomy so all of these
MLMs
and pyramid schemes are designed to prey
upon people who say hey okay I have a
job and I don't want to leave that job
but I would like a little extra money I
would like to build my own business and
be my own boss and work on my own time
and that's why people fall for it
because it is appealing it is actually
appealing but it is so so pernicious and
of course the number of people who even
make back their initial investment is
relatively small never mind you know the
number of people who ever make over a
thousand dollars period with any of
these things in profit is so
astronomically small and you're always
told about the success stories don't
fall for it don't fall for it there is a
there are endless resources online about
all of the companies that are MLMs and
pyramid schemes you'll notice I haven't
named any of them in this segment
because a lot of those companies are
very very litigious and I'm not
interested in that but please stop and
this is also to my friends please please
stop but you're falling for scams and it
just get focused on improving yourself
start a real small business if that's
what you're interested in doing
get just working a little more or
developing your skills so that you can
get a promotion I think that those are
much better uses of time and money than
participating in these MLM nonsense
schemes